it must feel very helpless
it is yeah
how frustrating is it for you there's
absolutely nothing I can do even though
I would like a chance to do anything how
do you connect with Evan when you're not
able to communicate with him
well we write letters
for 100 days Evan gershkovich's parents
and sister have tried to keep the
detained American Wall Street Journal
reporter spirits up while he sits in a
Moscow prison cell
they write letters to express their love
we think about you every minute of every
day and also to try and make him laugh
your hair's grown out so quickly soon
you'll have a very romantic look
I told him in one of those letters that
he is my prisoner now he has to go read
my stories that he didn't want to listen
to when he was younger
now he has to read them and he said that
don't worry about that I love your
stories keep writing them Evan was
detained during a reporting trip to
Russia in March and is Accused by the
Russian government of Espionage an
allegation The Wall Street Journal the
U.S government and his family strongly
deny the charges against him are
baseless
he is an innocent journalist and has
been wrongfully detained as he sits in
La fortivo prison his family says he's
missing out on things he loves covering
major news events attending friends
weddings and cheering on his favorite
sports teams there have been a lot of
developments in Russia in recent days
how much do you miss reading Evan's
byline and his stories
well I think he would be great you know
he covered
all the events there he would have made
an impact just seemed to be an itch for
him he just wanted to get the next story
in the next story and so I know that
must be
one of the hardest things right now have
there been any bright moments were when
we saw him
twice Evan's parents who left the Soviet
Union to become American citizens
traveled from Philadelphia to Moscow to
get a brief glimpse of their son in
court
at a hearing in June they were
unexpectedly permitted to speak with him
as he stood in a glass box known as the
aquarium and they were able to tell him
they love him I was just beside myself
so happy we were in deeply in our
conversation we were smiling and
laughing and the guard brought me back
to reality that I'm in a courtroom
my son is in this aquarium in this cage
and I had to realize where where I was
because I lost myself in that
conversation I was so happy to see him
seeing him just just brought brought him
a little bit back to me just uh physical
closeness made it a little bit more
bearable and how did he seem he seemed
uh he seemed well he seemed in good
spirits he was smiling it was he seemed
to be happy to see us as well Evan's
sister Danielle watched that hearing
from the U.S what was your reaction to
seeing them speaking I was just smiling
I was watching this video and I just
couldn't wipe the grin off my face I'm
just holding on to those things that are
bringing me joy right now
Evan's family has watched in person and
from afar as judges have ruled against
him upholding his detention extending it
and rejecting appeals to release him
after sharing a few precious minutes
with him his parents say they were
jolted back to reality you leave the
courtroom you leave the country tell me
about that yes reality it's even harder
now to leave him there
then it was the first time I I I uh try
not to think about anything but that's
just very hard
you don't want your mind to go there I
don't want my mind to go anywhere
the conviction rate in Russia is nearly
100 exactly
is there special in cases like that is
there anything about his case that gives
you hope
no
I rely on
President Biden's promise to do whatever
it takes to bring Heaven back I rely on
his team on their expertise in April the
U.S government officially designated
Evan as wrongfully detained launching a
government effort to pressure Russia to
free him there's no doubt that he's
being wrongfully detained by Russia
which is exactly what I said to foreign
minister lavrov when I spoke to him and
during the White House Correspondents
Dinner which Evan's family attended
President Biden called for his release
to the entire family
everyone in this Hall stands with you
we're working every day to secure his
release
he is an American Boy bringing him back
I think it's it's a team effort what's
keeping you going I have amazing support
um I have amazing parents just knowing
that our government is doing everything
in their power right now
um and
uh just everyone wants to help and and
is thinking about him and I just know
that we're not alone in this